they call this little Mogadishu and it's
home to a large Somali population in our
nomás political ascent and thanks to
this racist trope a lot of anxiety and
reflection too many here believe that
poisonous mix of racism and rage is
trumps 2020 strategy his stop walking
with him they might tell him this is the
way you come win a game so I think it is
all about that calculation she's gaining
when he tried to say something bad or
say like send her back or something like
that she's gaining new votes and new
people all of a sudden in this half
change and they have chanting worst so I
don't know where we are growing right
now because like I have no hope in there
in the culture at the airport the
Democrat freshman was welcomed with a
very different chart next stop a town
wall about healthcare policy after a
week of very personal attacks really
great to be home I know there are a lot
of people that are trying to distract us
now but I want you all to know that we
are not going to let down and the crowd
was right behind her to me she's far
more patriotic than
the people who are at the rally chanting
last night and when I hear that it makes
me afraid I'm concerned that Trump is
building militia to be honest with you
the 34 year old who's moved here as a
child was going nowhere
Donald Trump has cast her as a left-wing
ideologue who criticizes the country
that gave her shelter her supporters say
she's standing up for core American
values in the face of rising racism she
could well end up saying more about the
state of America than anyone else in
Congress this was a brief homecoming
after a lot of hostility but there will
likely be a lot more to come cordelia
land Sky News Minneapolis